[Music]
hello everyone it is Wednesday 11 a.m.
Pacific time here in San Frisco
California which you know what that
means it's time for the lobby
GameSpot's weekly video game hangout I'm
your host Mike McCarty here with Pete
Brownback for the first time in a couple
of weeks yeah it's been a while you went
to Tokyo I did yes we had from the
Australia office we're gonna get into
that today see what kind of news what
kind of demos you got to do you got to
see we did we talked about a little bit
of a some news that came out of it last
week like the zone of the enders of ER
well I'll tell you about Jing Kawas game
yeah left alive believe so we'll get
into all that doesn't sound like it'll
be too eventful but we'll talk about
anyway
Rob Hanley how are you what's up I'm
good
you started divinity original sin - I'm
off the boat yet and begin so we're
gonna side with that cuz since last week
when we talked about it for about half
an hour when John Luke was on the show
to substitute for you because he played
the game is a lot as well we gave it 10
or a freelance reviewer Brett Todd who's
been with us for a while he's also a
mayor yeah I keep forgetting I never
forget yeah he's yeah he's been with
GameSpot like longer than you right
because I was low I was researching some
stuff for an episode about like Baldur's
Gate - and there were quotes from him
yeah so a long time how my full circle
how big is the town that he mayor's like
it's like four dogs and a hamster
raccoons did he put in 70 hours in that
game in like just under two weeks I
don't know how he doesn't but he does it
Kelly clanking Becky hole hold on my
calls I gotta really click like I cook
like hi it's me hi you're playing
danganronpa I'm playing the the dangit
grandpa and yeah it's really long I've
been I put in I think 12 hours yesterday
yeah and I think I am almost done
there's a dog on the tracks on the way
into work today there was there was a
dog on the BART tracks but he's okay
thank God right people can get on people
people can take care of themselves but
dogs you need to actually worry about
the train the train is upside down yeah
it's still under the bay but my trains
ruining a bone
the trains ruined but the dog the dogs
also a marinara
as always we have a giveaway that I'll
get to later on the show so stick around
for that usual thing she will put it up
in the twitch chat and through our
GameSpot Twitter account I do have two
twitch and YouTube chats open as always
I do some news to get through
fortnight's battle royale mode is now
live that one that stirred up a torso
knee and on traversée yeah apparently
according to epics tweet today 1 million
people played at on opening day like
this mode they rode the party bus epic
said yeah which is the essentially the
plane that you ride it looks exactly the
same yep the island does to like all the
way down to the way that you're
parachuting in the way that the circle
closes in the circle of death the blue
fog kind of closes in force you into a
specific area it's all super it's not a
comedy it's Lots fired oh yeah plus you
know like plus the building aspects you
know it's weird because is this anthem
are we watching the anthem reading up on
what people think of it it does actually
sound like it fits but apparently it's
just a lot more boring because there are
no vehicles to start with that you can
use so you're just running across open
expansive lands land a lot of times when
you're avoiding the circle of death but
literally even down to the way that yeah
they're kind of fanning their parachute
to land a specific spot just it's buggy
which I guess like if you're gonna try
to clone something you might as well
clone something that what sold 10
million units just in early access I
mean there's a lot of games that that
borrow things from other games this
isn't the first time we can see itself
is like a conglomeration of ten
different inspirations well the
controversy though that like pub G was
built using unreal which is owned by
epic and epic makes fortnight and sort
of like during that process that because
maybe like hey guess what yeah the
actual tech behind the scenes stuff Tech
or whether it's just awareness of a
thing and evaluation of its quality
ahead of time yeah cuz I say there's
this it seems pretty robust not to speak
of its quality I haven't played it but
it seems like it's definitely took them
some time to do this I cannot see them
doing this in the time since they what
that soft launch I mean I will go on and
on about for tonight's pricing and how
dumb
but this moats free apparently which you
know judging by their past marketing I
don't know if that's actually true but
they say it is so you can go play this
it's live on PSN and I believe all
platforms actually but PSN was the one I
was reading the new start about that so
you go check that out if you're
interested in fortnight it's a battle
royale mode destiny two factions are now
live and as of yesterday so we can all
join dead orbit and not even talk about
future world for life yeah My Chemical
Romance songs the hot topic of the
Destiny universe did you join a attach
and Rob which one not that orbit orbit
please don't tell me you didn't you
wanna hear you monarchy that's like
there's a key there the cops that's like
the fascist call yeah there's like I
don't really care yeah like that shirt
you're wearing if you're watching the
show you can see Robin teh stream this
yesterday should be archived if you
wanna go check that out if you haven't
jumped into it of course if you've been
playing destiny to regularly probably
already aware of that but I figured I'd
do this little PSA I want to give an
grams to this depressed looking
individual why what's wrong with that
he just looks I want to make him happy
suspicious depressed people are
suspicious now don't judge a book by
taste I mean definitely three or five
now what's the wallet yeah I think so
I'm not super sure I'm still like 290
because yeah I'm not sure grinding a
bunch but not all day on twitch is
saying these guys are idiots get him out
of here pub she copied who h1h one copy
to ARMA no pub she was like made in our
Mateusz in ARMA 2 as a mod and then the
h1z1 kind of spawned off on itself but
it's the same person that's also Peter
brought up the point that games are
inspired by each other all the time I
think there are known behind driving
force behind them destiny 2 is you know
suspiciously similar to destiny 1 you
know
so burn it all day I do think a future
war cult has a cool like 70s aesthetic I
do I do like their aesthetic I might do
that for my Titan that I haven't made
yet but I plan on doing so you get
you're essentially giving York your
faction I don't know dude
a bunch of these tokens right there
factions specific and then you get what
are armor out of it yeah their
reputation it works similarly to the
other reputation stuff in the game so if
you've been doing crucible reputation or
whatever it is you get those tokens you
increase the reputation and then you get
an Engram that has like a bundle of a
set of armor and weapons so there's like
the dead orbits set and so what Tay has
been doing is he's been just farming
dead orbit coins to try to get the whole
set I had we played a whole bunch in
that stream and I didn't get like one
piece of armor from my there's yeah
there's also like random stuff you can
get and I fit sucks cuz he just showed
it he was just on that screen so but
yeah you can get shaders and stuff I
heard a neat thing that this update also
brought was that you know one of the I
guess gripes with the game was that lost
sectors as cool as they are you don't
really have much incentive to go through
them because the payoff is not that
great you know about the chess at the
end you mean right opposed to just going
for public events non-stop the only time
I do loss sectors is well there's no
when there are challenges but there's
also to get the it's the derm Drang and
Sturm there we go yeah keep wanting
durmstrang yeah so but yeah apparently
nothing you need to farm fallen it helps
anyway yeah apparently now with lost
sectors do you is where you um
they have like they've added basically
like these like kind of like three to
four supply crates that you shoot and
then that's where you get these these
tokens that are factions specific so
yeah you so yeah I guess I'm getting as
you're now more inclined to go through
loss sectors which I think was a nice
addition like those of us three of us
are dead orbit
his new monarchy yeah future war cult on
the lobby cast I also just like Peter
Stormare he's voice acting the dead
orbit guy it's escaped me right now the
most recent thing I saw him and he was
Chernabog and American Gods the show
he's no longer stuff tried bog mmm
that's a cool name oh it's the Russian I
forget there's a specific Russian like a
kind of religion that he pointed to I
believe this EXO Lakshmi is the same
voice actors Anna from overwatch I think
yeah someone said that these these are
good Ness classic graphics oh yeah we
will we do have a sense classic in the
office so we will get to that later on
the show probably toward the end we also
got a steamworld dig to review up on
GameSpot mattis Spinelli unfortunately I
don't think any of us got the chance to
play it because I played oh you did a
little bit yeah a touch on the switch so
obviously the sequel it's more it's kind
of like minecraft mixed with
Metroidvania yeah Metroidvania how you
just played on the switch how was that
yeah um we gave it a 9 sorry that's why
I brought it up I had to play more I
honestly but it to me like I'm just I'm
I probably played like 45 minutes last
night and I was just I feel like I've
seen this type of game before mm-hmm
like it may be like iOS just like yeah
I'm just digging a hole grabbing war
going back flipping it for upgrades and
stuff and I was just I don't know like I
have to play more but I guess we're
gonna add as I I didn't feel like there
was anything like different or like
catchy for me to like churn keep playing
like I feel like I've just seen this
done before but I don't know the crux of
the review in Matt's opinion and one of
the things that he really looked about
the game was the idea of mods that you
can you know generate after collecting
stuff and how that impacts your
abilities and then how that feeds into
what you can explore right it's that
loop of character progressions and
progression and then being able to go
deeper into the world so yeah say 45
minutes probably isn't the right amount
of time to get to that point so that was
the thing is like within the last few
minutes is where I like did like my
second or third like you know trip back
with all this or and then I was looking
at the upgrades and stuff like that and
that's where I was like okay yeah
I could I could play a little more yeah
yeah but pretty much across the board
people are really happy with this game
it's remote really well and it's so it's
I don't know where it falls in the
series because there's like three games
there's two steamworld dig z' and
there's steam world heist which is like
a tactical turn-based game if I remember
correctly interesting series mm-hmm yeah
the it seems tailor-made for the switch
I think that's why I might pick it up
eventually just because I don't know if
I would sit there and dig through no pun
intended
get through this game on the you know
any other platform the switch seems kind
of like it having handheld and being on
maybe like a commuter flight would be
perfect mm-hmm
so yeah that is up on you so if you
can't want to go read that so like man
it's been only gave it a 9 out of 10
this we're about of to I'm one of the
many high-scoring
reviews or one of the few high scoring
reviews this week we put up a few uh a
few reviews and then in other news the
video game voice actor strike that
started last October sag-aftra yeah what
is that Screen Actors Guild
what's the Afro for always farting
trying always that's after months they
agreed to some of the terms they I know
they were initially talking about they
wanted back-end payments when a game
that they worked on would sell like a
certain milestone like a hundred
thousand five hundred thousand copies
that sees essentially yeah they didn't
get that agreement but they did get this
kind of like exponential pay you do one
hour in the first hours like $75
something then the next one it just goes
up exponentially and dull straight until
like 1500 an hour or something so yeah
that's great I I think I would like to
see the voice actors get some sort of
royalties especially considering you
look at games like divinity original sin
to the voice acting is phenomenal it's
just in so robust I can't even imagine
how long some those people like yeah in
that booth like hours and hours so
hopefully that uh that works out well
that's been going on for about eleven
months now and it seems like it's almost
completely resolved it just seems good
for both parties
alright Tokyo Game Show Tokyo games
should say it's pretty uneventful Peter
it was pretty uneventful
they have press days they have business
days but even so they don't really have
a lot of
english-speaking people Manning the
booths so and you have a lot of people
there you know like any event who are
press stole long lines like to our waits
to play some games which which we don't
really have time for so I didn't get to
play
Yakuza for example which was kind of
disappointing I didn't get to play this
aku top jock Zack you want me to okay so
it's the remake of two in the new engine
unlike the remake of one which is in the
older ps3 engine just slept like up
rezzed basically well there's a lot more
to it but wasn't the English
localization or was it in Japanese it
would have been in Japanese yes those
games are pretty you know beyond the
dialog very easy to discern
right stuff like that so what I did get
to play I will talk about that the most
and the thing that I was looking forward
to the most and didn't realize it was
gonna be at the show was this game
called tiny metal this is an advanced
for spiritual successor okay
unapologetic about that but it brings
some new things to the table it allows
for sort of like co-op attacks on an
enemy so right you know every enemy gets
to counter-attack but if you can get two
guys attacking during one turn then they
at the enemy still only gets one
counter-attack there you go small
addition otherwise its Advance Wars you
progress through fog of war you take
over buildings you build new units and
you try to take down the enemy it's got
really great art style really great
personality and it's coming like every
single platform one of the son we spent
about an hour playing in that game I
think and it was the highlight of the
show by far even though it's not like a
Japanese game necessarily how long it
was Advance Wars now I think days of
ruin was the last one maybe I heard I
forget I think maybe there was like a
DES acronym but it was des was the last
system and was there is anybody on this
team like from the advance wars that
they do super soft I'm aware of no but
you know again it's like no one's really
doing anything with that series so these
kind went for it and the presentation is
far more rich than what you would see
from an advanced Wars game which were
always 2d and pixelated which looked
good but this takes things into 3d as a
very you know polished like 3d cartoon
aesthetic that works really well and
it's not it's not too goofy or anything
like that but it is charming in its own
way so that game looks really good yeah
did you see anything more than we did
about left alive the Yoji Shinkawa the
game yo dishing I was working on oh
there was there was nothing at the show
about that easy right yeah I mean what
we
do you pretty much know based on an
interview I think translated by Dengeki
PlayStation is that this is likely
taking place in the same universe as the
front mission series okay which is a
series of screen it hasn't really done
anything within a long time
those were tactical games as a return
based grid you know you you customized
mechs and in really deep engaging ways
and in Jana but in this case you are on
the ground as a third-person action game
and you are fighting against mix and
then we kind of saw some of that in the
teaser trailer like very quick snippets
of gameplay and it's the person who is
doing a lot of the mech designs has done
a lot of them for Xenoblade Chronicles X
Gundam double zero I think and maybe
also Armored Core but the armored core
person might actually be the the lead
designer I I forgot that the order of
those names but it in your jooshin kala
obviously and the concept artist at
Kojima Productions or dub Metal Gear did
some stuff for Call of Duty as well this
year yeah well I'm very curious about
left alive I'm also very cautious about
left alive yeah my initial thing was I
loved all of yo judging how was work but
when just the art director doesn't make
a great game but like obviously hearing
everybody else yeah the other people
involved it does sound promising but
third person action you know it's really
easy to have it not feel good and like I
feel like I was watching that teaser and
I saw some some animations or some
camerawork tied together I was just like
crap something about this has me worried
but we'll see because we literally saw
seconds of gameplay so way too early to
judge I have no familiarity with front
mission at all it's it's essentially
very serious war stories with people
building up mechs and you can customize
guns types of ammo armor I mean like
it's almost overwhelming what you can
customize in your mechs in those games I
it started on the Super Nintendo we
didn't actually get it until the
original playstation with front mission
3 and then it continued on ps2 and I
think we got one or two more of those
but it's largely been a series in Japan
did you get to check out wait no we
played zone of the enders VR which they
announced you did like someone did I did
oh you did yesterday or YouTube or
something and I just saw it's like it's
it doesn't seem great or like all that
well adapted for VR yo that was you okay
how is it it's ok what you're looking at
right now this is not the VR portion
this is the VR portion gotten to to go
back to what we were initially seeing
I'll talk about this first whatever
screw it
so the VR stuff they put me in a booth
you put me in a headset that gave me the
controller and they're like all right so
you're facing off against these huge
ships you have to take them down one by
one
the level will end now though the
Ender's a lot of what you do is you use
weapons that lock on to things and you
sort of like you know like over trigger
and you send out these little tracer
missiles and stuff like that and you
also have melee attacks in general just
sort of you know missiles that you can
fire that just go straight ahead so
using those tools I was supposed to
fight these ships and like it was it was
kind of working but the controls were a
little bit clumsy and that part became
really evident when they got me like ok
you've shot down all the things on the
ship but now you need to like go into
its back and like stand on the ground
and attack this other thing that sort of
rules of the mechanics and how you
engage against enemies like kind of
shifted and the control simply didn't
work mmm I had people at the booth like
holding my headphones up and like press
this button press this button I'm like
I'm holding it up like I might get
frustrated at all no I'm pressing go no
seriously it was like I have no idea
what to tell you this doesn't work and
and in it it really wasn't working I
mean there was it was like oh well you
need to be standing on the ground it's
like how can I see if I'm standing on
the ground what are you talking about
like I'm gonna flying mech why why oh
and I said it why would my why would
that dictate what my weapon can do
whether my feet are touching the ground
or not I got a weird rash in that little
area on my leg
somehow we shot that video brings back
bad memories
exact so what's weird is that sigh games
is behind this development sigh games
made granblue fantasy a game none of us
pay attention to maybe we've heard of
it's a popular mobile game it had the
biggest booth at TGS a couple years ago
essentially it's a mobile company trying
to get its feet wet and dip into the
console space and Konami is working with
them and I can't say that I'm very
confident about where it's headed based
on what I played ok but outside of VR is
known in the under second Runner is a
very good very unique kind of
3d action game with mechs it certainly
ties into people's love for Konami
there's like a lot of gradius references
in it as well like you fight vic viper
at one point which is pretty rad so to
have that back on PlayStation 4 will be
really good they did remaster those
games for ps3 but the the port on ps3
was not that great even after a patch it
still had low framerate issues and some
weird anti-aliasing stuff so we get the
best zone of the enders game on a modern
console hopefully that port is a lot
better the VR stuff wait to see but
right now I I'm not excited about it
kind of timid I'm very wary word that's
what the headline was for today alright
it was it that's yeah something about
being wary anything else with TGS that I
didn't mention I played some of the new
ace combat did you I did and he liked it
quite a bit not you yeah I know not mean
unfortunately but he's very stoked about
that game and I'm interested because you
show me that new mechanic that they've
got yeah this sort of like stalling it
out it's like an air brake like you see
it done in a lot of movies I don't know
like to what extent that start was
actually realistic sure but just
basically like you know engagingly flaps
and it's like you know having someone on
your six shoot forward proposed to which
is where like I mean I love flat flight
Sims and dogfighting but eventually you
can like strain your hand because you
find yourself in like an hour-long
circle with another guy and get one shut
off and then they passed me again it
just seems like a really cool way to
change it up or you yeah you just hit
the air brake and let him fly forward
but even like what was neat is it wasn't
just hitting an air brake it was like
you're cool yeah like you know it's like
you had like a free access to basically
like pivot up and down or do a flip it
was something that I haven't seen done
in a lot of or Eminem I personally
haven't seen in like flight games that
seem to catch ange up like a nice
bindings of dogfighting I'd yeah it does
it looks really cool is this gonna be in
VR oh I hope so I'm not sure it's like
cockpit games and Jeff yeah it's gonna
be awesome
other than that I played the two new
Earth Defense Force games so there's
like Earth Defense Force like
for point one and then another one
called iron storm so if I'm getting 4.1
correctly maybe it's five at this point
but that one is using the old engine and
it's like yeah this is Earth Defense
Force right you just sort of like a
Ranger with a gun is shooting down yeah
but this one I think it's called iron
storm or something like that this is
really rad you've got this like
exoskeleton they're using a brand new
engine you have all these new sort of
like maneuvers and capabilities as a
soldier on the ground this actually
finally felt like like I'm not a huge
fun series to play so dumb and
therapeutic yeah it's great yeah so but
to have it advanced a little bit is both
surprising and I'm happy about it
because I might actually play this for
you know a weekend for fun so that was
pretty rad I'd also forgot when I was
talking to John Luke about bureau but
code vane is shaping up to be pretty
good oh I'm really excited about that
so challenging as you'd expect for the
reasons you'd expect being a Dark Souls
like but it also is very focused on
dungeon crawling so vampire one right
yeah so it's very focused on dungeon
crawling and you also have an NPC with
you at all times that you sort of work
in concert with and they can help
protect you and you have to kind of work
with them and there are like a bunch of
different ones you can collect so it
seems like it's it's chasing the Dark
Souls formula in some respects but it's
also doing its own thing and it also
looks really good it just frankly just
looks great presentation level number
when they first showed that trailer it
was just super gothic vampire stuff so
yeah I mean blood-borne at least one for
the Gothic kind of horror stuff yeah it
was you know it's it's bright when it's
not black you know the thing about the
trailer as I loved the art direction of
that trailer and then the actual game
didn't have that art style so I was
surprised it was more like the trailer
was kind of setting a tone but like I
saw it at e3 and I saw like one area
that was kind of like all brown I'm glad
to hear there's a little more style to
it I guess oh yeah and you played it I'd
played it okay I was busy doing
interviews and stuff oh man can I talk
about like the coolest moment at TGS
yeah when I got pulled into a back room
to interview Yuzo Koshiro with like no
warning and if that mean name means
nothing to you you need to look him up
because he is like one of the best video
game composers out there has you know
Streets of Rage 2 is known as one of the
most interesting soundtracks of all
video console games he's responsible for
that he's like I don't get freaked out
by Kojima or Miyamoto or whoever I was
beside myself talking to this dude like
and I had no warning some was just like
yeah you want to go talk to you zero it
was like I mean no yes no I don't know
is there anyone else like game developer
why's that that would happen with in
your experience for me it sounds generic
but Miyamoto would probably be mine yeah
I mean I
the one time I talked to Mia moto was
after playing starfox to and uses like
so how do you like it I just played it
earlier no sorry not Star Fox - oh he
was like watching us play it and like
then was asking us what we thought about
it and everyone was kind of like oh it's
okay no I mean music Oshiro is like I've
talked to you know the creator of Final
Fantasy Tactics you sumimasen know like
that was a pretty big deal for me back
in the day but using Koshiro sort of
exudes cool like I feel like even
someone like Kojima I feel like his
approach bulk Kushiro was it's hard to
characterize what like the environment
he was in without getting a little blue
here but it was one of those scenes
where I was like [ __ ] this feels like
I'm behind stage at a rock concert or
something like and this guy is not to be
trifled with
and your tank gun yeah okay he was very
friendly he's very open but he just
definitely has this sort of like
imposingly cool nature about him yeah I
know that site so that was pretty
fantastic I also got to talk to suda51
which we get access to him quite a bit
we were talking about the silver case
the follow-up sequel and the Slover case
isn't a game that gets wide acclaim or
anything like that so I kind of really
wanted to talk to him
because the game deals a lot with like
murder and I wanted to figure out why do
you care about death so much he's like
well it's not so much that I care about
death it's coming for all of us yeah but
he was like you know what I'm trying to
convey in this game is if the sequel to
the Civil War is called the 25th Ward
and what that essentially are the silver
case is the 25th Ward and what that's
setting up is a new ward in Tokyo where
the government sort of plants
people based on who they want to be
there and it's sort of like really nice
stuff they're like really nice places
like these like mansion towers they're
called and so essentially these people
are forced there by the government but
they like being there but also they
don't really know to do it themselves
and they fall apart and people start
killing each other and stuff like that
and so we had a very interesting
conversation with him but also his
co-director who's been working with him
forever that I don't think anyone ever
talks to and so we had a really
interesting conversation about you know
growing up outside of Tokyo how they
felt that cities sort of characterized
like their dreams as a kid and where
them brought them how they characterized
their I you know ideation of crime and
stuff like that so I'll be publishing
that review later this week so that was
really refreshing that was that was a
good review he's like the best interview
interview yeah okay cool um any other
last-minute things from I don't know do
you guys have a developer that you would
like your dream interview will be when I
met the creator of danganronpa he said
that people who are fans of danganronpa
his knock coma
and I was like pretend I don't know what
that means I'm not gonna it's like it's
like comrade it's like Brothers in Arms
it's like greater than friendship or
like being a fan like he was like
they're not fans they're my Knock I was
like that was like your favorite I I
have interviewed well I shadowed a
miyamoto interview once so I was pretty
starstruck and meeting Masada from
Pokemon was pretty cool cool wanna meet
me shihara from Thoth 1 no not
necessarily I don't know any like you
got to talk the titanfall 2 devs for
like an entire day would you yeah but
that was before you knew that was gonna
be one of your favorite games ever that
was like a preview event we did yeah
that was a fun event though that was but
that was when we were like oh god this
game actually is something all of the
Star Wars had during the interview Jar
Jar Binks what huh
you got to interview Jar Jar Binks I got
to interview Jar Jar Binks if he did oh
if I did what would she say to him I'd
say I'm sorry I'm sorry about are you
trying to do his voice yeah
I just felt like using koshiro's when
those people that you would never
interview like why would you he's not
out there marketing games he's not
really talked about that often among
like games media and stuff yeah or by
developers or studios and then but he's
pretty important he's a cool dude yeah
84 gesture acts new YouTube chess and I
would love to meet Shinji Mikami I would
as well yeah did you talk to him didn't
you four people in - yeah I talked to
Shinji Mikami what's this
the interview did not go as I had hoped
mm-hmm continue they're about to ship a
video game and I think that they are
short on patience because the games not
good let's put it this way the end of
the the end of the conversation from
QuakeCon he told Alessandra look I'm
very proud of my team we developed this
game in a much shorter time than the
last one there were a lot of challenges
we overcame and for everyone involved
you know I'd give it to you like good
job on doing that so I started the
interview I was like okay I remember you
said to my colleague recently that you
made this game in a very short amount of
time and there were some challenges
I'm curious can you tell me what these
challenges were and he was like well I
mean yeah there's a shorter amount of
time but you know any sequels you're
gonna make it faster than the first one
I was like no I okay but you said there
were challenges my colleague and he was
and he didn't he didn't care for my line
of questioning he was very dismissive to
the point where he was telling the
director to answer questions instead
mm-hmm Wow the director was more
accommodating but I look they were also
facing a day of press interviews and
like we showed up at the end of that day
to conduct our interview I think they
were tired I can't fault them for being
tired because look the press all want to
know the same [ __ ] we all ask the same
questions at the end of the day pretty
much that interaction it didn't go as
planned yeah I I can't I can't I can't
say one way or another whether he's a
nice guy or not but that in that
interview was one of them the more
frustrating for me
resin evil 7 turned out to be a great
game but I remember like when I was at
Gamescom interviewing some of the
producers on the game half the interview
was them clarifying like something they
said to us in a previous interview about
like silent hill's comparisons because
it's called backpedaling
and they spent especially with
translation everything's I don't speak
Japanese they were a lot of it the
literally half of the half-hour
interview was them clarifying something
that like alright now I get to ask my
own questions and it sucks sometimes but
yeah ah cool any other last minute TGS
stuff go to Tokyo if you get the chance
flights are cheap flights are very cheap
I want to go you want to talk about Goku
like we're gonna sure what are you dirty
money Goku Goku is all over Tokyo you
run to a convenience store guess what
he's selling shampoo mm-hmm any toy
store you go to there's a thousand Goku
toys I tried to take as many pictures as
I could of Goku around Tokyo and I hope
to put up a gallery of that someone
sometime soon different beautiful
dresses Goku know the real Goku yeah
Goku himself yeah the worst father in
the world
that's Tokyo Game Show we got a bunch of
news stories and videos and impressions
up from Peter and edy from Australia
offices who made the trip to Tokyo last
week welcome back again thank you
welcome back to the storm of review
season yeah you got there like right
kind of during after the typhoon because
that one was it the same one that hit
China cuz another one hit China as well
like apparently went up the east coast
of Asia maybe it was yeah before it hit
Japan my buddy was just in China and
said it was pretty bad when I got there
everyone was like it's overblown it's
fine there they're like these missiles
though funny story I heard a couple
times was it's a Japanese typhoon it's
very polite and efficient I was like
okay polite polite and efficient okay
because this is Japanese - yes thank you
very much that's what they were telling
me wise to typhoons as well gotcha it
wasn't a big deal
well that's good that it wasn't too bad
heat signature again they came out last
week I tried it out for a few hours and
I liked it a lot I guess the best way I
could describe it so people looking at
the screen will just be like oh it looks
like FTL this is a very top-down
perspective of these ships but it's more
akin to hotline miami mixed with rogue
legacy so but a slower pace
line Miami so I don't want to talk too
much about because I think I'm the only
one who played it but I will say you
should try it out like I put it on Steam
and it's it's worth saying that it's
like a hotline Miami if it were slower
and then you know slower paced you're
trying to figure out like okay this gun
is recharging so I could use my wrench
against this guy and then punch this guy
pick up his gun and kill the third guy
that's kind of hotline Miami but this is
all playing out at a much slower pace to
the point where you're pausing time
right yes you it's actually like that's
almost from fallout you'll you press the
base bar look at what tools you have
look at like the reload timer on your
gun this is all like energy weapons or
most of them looking around the room and
then kind of like lining up a shot with
your crosshairs and then pressing space
again to unpause it and like your health
is fairly low right yeah you're very one
or two hits and you're done
yep if that the point on that it's two
hits but you get like a left click
button a right click button like I said
you could pause it you can you get a
teleport tool so you can kind of say you
know teleport this keycard to me so I
can open this door and go get this
weapon but it's like rogue legacy in the
sense that you go back to this hub to
get contracts and it's pretty cool in
terms of procedural generational
storytelling it'll say oh this mercenary
has beef with this pirate captain so the
only mission is to go kill that pirate
captain or this person is a bounty
hunter so go capture this person alive
or this person needs this to escape to
this world it's also cool like when
you're transitioning between missions
and going back to the hub you're
actually piloting the ship and zooming
out to like a right solar system view
and then back into an actual like you
have to match the speed kind of
interstellar but not nearly as
complicated of the space the ship that
you're trying to board and you look on
it it looks pretty cool yeah it's simple
its sights it's you know left mouse
click accelerates and then right breaks
and you have to match speed it was a
very fun game I'd highly encourage
people to check it out like I said if
you'd like how about hotline Miami you
should like this like I said slower
paced but still the same kind of minute
second a second planning when you want
different ships and whatnot if you like
legacy you might like this a lot I
really like C's one of my favorite games
and this reminded me that because one
year when your certain characters die
you will get a bunch of new ones with
different motivations I kind of just
contextualize why you're going to the
ship and killing this cat
can you like can you like eject people
out into space yes you can throw them
through like you can shoot windows
airlock windows it's pretty cool you can
but you can also like hit the if there's
a locked door you can hit the wall with
your wrench so three guys will come
through the lock door and I'm like for
you if you can't just teleport the
keycard to you this is the hub right
here you can talk to different people
and buy stuff upgrades and whatnot you
can see here when you go talk to the
potential recruits it'll say you know
there'll be easy medium and hard
missions so the easiest will be like oh
I've got beef with this captain I'm
gonna need to go kill him media won't be
like I need to go kappa this dude alive
third will be like I don't know if I've
done the expert level missions yet but I
imagine it would be more like you need
to commandeer the ship kill everyone on
it and also extract this in a certain
time limit yeah this game is really fun
I highly encourage you guys check it out
and anybody watching or listening it's
it's very fun it's like I said if you
liked any of those influences that I
mentioned but it's very much its own
thing obviously but it's worth checking
out Matt Padgett GameSpot is in our
YouTube chat he says he also recommends
it what up Matt yeah cool a game that
more of us played ruiner I actually
don't know much about it what's the
elevator pitch
cyberpunk twin-stick shooter with a
bunch attitude people were when I
nevermind I do know about this game
reviews people were comparing at the
hotline Miami maybe that's just because
of the problem Amy's not even site you
die you die often like all I meant like
you're repeating stages pretty often
okay
I've played about an hour once again
life definitely length of play for these
games I'm talking about is has been
phenomenal this game is you know the the
intro of this game which I it's kind
it's a frustrating experience I had
where was like they're throwing all
these mechanics at you and it's tough in
that you have like a bunch of things as
far as ability abilities you have like
an energy based tree that you can like
change I guess later on it's like
shield but it it does pull from
resources like an energy meter that you
have to refill at different stages you
also have a - and then you have this
time slowing chain that you can set up
like three waypoints again with the
stick so you can like basically make
like a like a three-pointed - move and
engage your shield to knock back enemies
and enemies come in waves
some of them shoots moving wield
crowbars okay so I could actually see
how that's kind of like a hotline miami
thought-process
you Sherlock Holmes pause time to think
out what you're gonna do right Guy
Ritchie Sherlock Holmes - but what was
nothing and I would expect the more you
play obviously the more you you get a
sense of like how to like get your mind
around it but it's just those three
things I just mentioned Oh as well as
shooting and you have a melee option it
was just they throw it at you so quickly
that like I was just like man I I'm
trying to like I just want to worry
about one of these things one one me
like like you know I just want to be
able to shoot and get and get that skill
honed but I guess you had you have to
use it yeah but ultimately women getting
a - is like you have to use all of those
three abilities in in out you know
simultaneously Channel excuse me um in
sync like if you aren't utilizing one of
them then you're gonna die there the
trailer itself the first one in the
launch trailer just like went through
every single gun in the game and it was
just like shotgun phase drifter yeah
like one of those games this footage is
being played at the mouse and keyboard
and you were playing with the controller
on ps4 yeah right that's very curious
about the yeah yeah it's like is it even
a twin stick shooter you're playing on
PC technically but what was that what
you say oh yeah I taught me does the
relationship between moving and aiming
you know feel that much feel
significantly different based on the
control scheme you've got yeah WWE ASD
would seem really difficult from
movement I would assume and then a mouse
yeah but controllers if it felt fine it
was just though like getting a grasp on
how to like use all these things at once
because
the guys were coming the guys who are
wielding guns will are the ones that
generally kill me because even when I'm
slowing down time to like think about
these waypoints I'm gonna set up for
myself to like - new people time isn't
slowing down that much so like if you
don't if you don't like act quick in
those moments you're gonna get hit
because the bullets are not slowing down
and they're pretty precise as far as
like shooting you yeah just watching
this fudge I am like I'm not even
playing this game and I'm a little
annoyed at all of the instructions at
the top like does that get annoying when
you're playing where it's like do this
fill your energy meter kill the boss
because for me I'm like I got it the
kill the boss thing is reminds me like
superhot it's just like killed ball yeah
that's this game in general remind you
of superhot yeah a little bit self-aware
kind of tone sure yeah I'd say it's it's
like more aggressive in that respect
with like its style it's like when we're
grittier like raunchy even like so where
I began to see this game getting at
least enjoyable was like this is again
this is like kind of like the tutorial
right here you're just like you know
it's like a just escape from this like
starting area you you then get into it I
can open a area like an open-world area
where there's no shooting yours kind of
interacting doing a little bit like
fetch quests like in like a kind of like
urban area but I think what's neat is
that these abilities I described there's
a pretty extensive tree so again you're
kind of like separating things as far as
like you know basic stat things you can
focus on like health and melee attack
but energy and you're dashing like you
can upgrade the tree but then at any
point you can wipe it and start again
and and focus on something that maybe
you're more keen on Rhys pecking yeah
like a you do that at any point which I
thought was nice because yeah yeah as
far as all the abilities go it was it
was just like kinda hard to grasp seems
overwhelming a little bit but I don't
know I I do hear some good things about
it like later on like the more you play
the more like
you you find like your play style it's
it's they're like oh yeah cool uh yeah
this is also another interesting factoid
this is recon recon games recon this is
the first devolver digital published
game to go to Xbox one on day one hmm
so that's good so they seem to be
branching out but it's on PC ps4 Xbox
one steam and GOG if that's where you
get your PC games GOG cool we're out
thanks for selling that game I want to
play more are you interested to play
more yeah definitely
we do have a review up on GameSpot calm
yeah we give it a grade out of 10 a
great at a 10 it's great thank you for
that cool I want to talk before we get
to read dead hypotheses for the teaser
tomorrow and the senesce classic overall
impressions there's a review for that
Michael hi I'm Michael from the weekend
divinity like I said we gave it a
essential score 10 out of 10
yep I don't care what games you like or
don't like you need to play this game
which is I was looking back through the
catalog of 10 out of tens or what 13 now
no no after Zelda 14 right and because
we call it essential it struck me as
like and I agree this game is fantastic
and never liked so many ways and I can't
put it down but it seems like one of the
more niche games to get a 10 out of 10
that's true like Zelda
uncharted 4 melody Solid five row no
gloss chrono this is the second from a
freelancer right and the definition of
10 has changed over the years at one
point it it would say perfect well
there's a boat's thing wasn't perfect
yeah another point it I think said
masterpiece well you could debate with
hell that means from but a game that we
really believe in the one that
supersedes genre and preference is one
that we like to call essential and I
think you know even as someone who has
you know dabbled in computer RPGs in the
past like not really fun in love with
the genre it's not something I seek out
I spent 45 minutes in this game and I
was the word I keep using his smitten
because I just felt so delighted by
everything I was seeing overwhelmed but
also excited about being overwhelmed
with so many things because even the
little things that I understood were
leading me down a path of discovery and
surprise mm-hm and I just I just could
imagine all that was left out there
and then you have to take into account
all the production values right like
everything is voice at a million words
of dialogue for all possible you played
the most right I'm at our I'm an act - I
think our 30 to 35 right Ben chenkin and
John Luke or the two in our office aside
from Brett Todd or freelancer who
reviewed it that have played the most I
think Ben he's an our YouTube check on
crazy right now so how do you feel about
the designation of essential do you feel
like this is a game that and yeah do
keep in mind that it's fair to have
we're fair to have our own opinions here
yeah Brett Todd is the reviewer and we
felt like he sold that opinion
so they he did yeah I have some gripes
the game like again 10 doesn't mean it's
perfect but uh but it was very much like
I've only back when I was reviewing
games for us I gave one chart for a 10
out of 10 people disagree with that yeah
I I think some of this game it's
actually it's crazy how much you can do
jean-luc who's in our back room right
now put it really well he said this is
the closest he's ever felt that a video
game has gotten to like pen and paper or
D&D right we're all fueled by your
imagination as you can imagine and just
tell this story this game is very very
hard to find those limitations and
that's easy enough to like say that's
impressive on its own but the fact that
it still feels contained but it's also I
was telling you this morning Pete I like
realize for the first time you know you
look at I want to talk a little bit more
about like the definition of a computer
RPG and kind of baldur's gate stuff but
you look at you look at the stuff that
like Bioware has done since maybe
Baldur's Gate 2 or Neverwinter Nights
it's been you know the morality systems
in the choice you make are often binary
Paragon or renegade in Mass Effect or
you know nice little public you could be
like a Sith or a Jedi or kind of
straddle the mill ground many RPGs are
like that and you're taking this chaotic
world and kind of making it this binary
choice system this doesn't really have
good or bad right this doesn't have good
or bad this game I actually realized for
maybe the first time since like Baldur's
Gate 2 or the first time like I can
really remember this game itself is
actually changing the way I make
decisions like I'm not I'm not imposing
my morality on the game the game is
making me rethink what should be what's
right and wrong but oftentimes it's just
it's crazy to see how many inter
connecting systems will like like these
Mergent things will come out of it so
I'm actually encouraged to do something
just to introduce chaos to the world and
not vice-versa and see what happens
because it's so entertaining and just
like deep in terms of what kind of
Domino effects and chain reactions will
happen every interaction feels promising
yeah yeah something something fantastic
that you didn't expect was going to
happen and like it's it's the it is the
yeah what are those poses really quick
here
yeah we're switching between class
it's the purest role-playing game I
played in such a long time in the fact
that it's gonna sound dumb I'm actually
really playing a role and kind of all my
characters are like Pete I was telling
you right here this is perfect timing
because I was an undead character so for
most of the which is like a hardcore
choice to make but I I would recommend
it because no you're right um I know
like I think me Ben no Ben's a dwarf
John Luke maybe his brothers and Undead
I don't know something like but
essentially yeah like we talked about
this last week you know it's harder
because people are afraid of you if you
don't have a helmet that covers your
face or a bucket for the first five
hours because I haven't alluded a good
helmet my character also just I needed a
ranged character because I was getting
destroyed up close so I need someone
like behind my the red Prince or my
rogue Sabeel to help him from a range so
I just gave my main character crossbow
his finesse is like the baseline for
that crossbow so he misses all the time
and he's not mobile off to get to the
high ground have better accuracy it's
almost like it sounds kind of hyperbolic
or dramatic on my part but I'm actually
like I kind of like that he saw it
sucked for a while because yeah the
moment wears a helmet yeah it's hard to
feel like cool when you have a helmet on
your head for five hours and people were
running fear from you break it [ __ ] yeah
yes sorry it gives you armor like a
helmet would though it's like yeah yeah
so you can yeah you can be a human or an
elf and wear it and it still work well
the dissection of the undead is that
potions will hurt them yeah you have to
like heal yourself with like I I just
found out I have one of the most useful
items for the undead I have an item that
can turn potions or like certain
substances into poison and I didn't even
know I had it for like ten hours I don't
even know what it would do oh I thought
you're gonna say that you have a
skeleton key
reviews your finger and eye and I forgot
and I didn't even know until 10 hours in
that you could pick locks with your
skeleton fingers and then and then
jean-luc and Rob simultaneously like
skeleton key and but I just didn't have
a high enough thievery skills though I
could do that yeah I do want to say that
one of the things that's most exciting
to me about this game going back to John
Luke's like this being close to a pen
and paper tabletop RPG is that that's
something I've been interested in for a
while but I was never confident in my
imagination enough to do that and I like
that this kind of my impression so far
of divinity has been like a platform for
for me - not me but like every you said
every interaction has promised and the
idea of that is to me is like oh now I
don't have to rely solely on myself I
can I can the game is like shaping my
journey through the story if that makes
sense
yes which is something that I just was
always afraid of with D&D that I would
just do something extremely boring and
everyone would be like why'd you do that
right you know but having this to be
like oh well something interesting is
going to happen so I can just kind of
experiment and have a good time yeah and
to that point I mean you know the
decisions you make will lead to a number
of different outcomes I'm paraphrasing
our reviewer because I'm still very
early in this game just to be clear but
the idea you know being that you can
fail and you'll never see what would
have come from victory you know a person
can die in a quest you'll just never
have a chance to get it and that person
will die for reasons that seem
inconsequential but you might not even
know you missed that quest until the
next time you play that game and that
character doesn't die that time yeah
it's so sorry Rob it's it's we're not
playing I keep thinking back to Mass
Effect just because that you know like
people say there were these choices or
the Sophie's Choice where you don't do
you either kill Caden or Ashley it's
always Caden but like or like it's
paragate Paragon or renegade like
they're always kind of black and white
and like more recently RPGs well not for
a long time now but like RPGs lately you
know like witcher 3 had some cool like
emergent stuff that would happen if you
did this quest and then you saw this
npcs grave later on like 30 hours later
and didn't even know is there but like
this game is so good at like like
it actually encourages you to play a
role because it's one thing in those
games to make these intentional
decisions and the characters like this
avatar for you to be good whereas this
game is more you could accidentally kill
someone like I did like when you write
like started a fight on accident like
[ __ ] now we have to play out and you
could reload a save but in this game
like aside from like a combat encounters
gone wrong like any RPG or any you know
glitch you might want to you save off
and just f5 all the time but I've
reloaded this game way less than I ever
did with like Skyrim everything because
accidents happen and that kind of shades
your character like it's more about the
consequences than the decisions you make
and also how those consequences affect
your decisions and like I can't say
enough about how borderline like no like
more like brilliant this game is at
facilitating or encouraging you to just
like kind of roll the punches because
you might kill this crucial NPC but if
he's not alive to give you this quest
you can have your elf eat one of his
limbs to get the memory or you can
search for another two hours are you
gonna go do something else then find a
note related to that or someone who knew
him and you can you start to see behind
the scenes a little bit about how Larian
is kind of making sure that you could
still do this quest even if you kill all
these people
but if you're not if you're just like
rolling with it it feels so great it's
so impressive that sort of what I was
getting at is like the freedom to create
your own story without the pressures of
like the burden of doing it all yourself
so like I know like with Mass Effect I I
always go Paragon with with any like
Bioware like with kotor 2 like i just i
have a really hard time being mean to
npcs but with divinity it's more like
well something interesting will happen
so i don't have to like confined myself
to the pressures of how I would normally
act or the things that I would normally
think of doing even in a fantasy world
if that makes sense sort of what I was
getting it yeah it like everyone's
basically like same sentiment with me it
was just like I'm still on that goddamn
first boat yet I had like all these like
the same experiences but was with one
sigh but it was a character basically
like you find yourself like realizing
I'm just gonna go with my gut because it
doesn't really
matter in the end you know and opposed
to with so many other RPGs like yeah you
mentioned Mass Effect where it's like
okay I feel like I'm approached those
games or have in the past where I'm
ultra I'm like a detective I'm trying to
like pull out what I need to say with
the choices because there's only one
right you trying to get the perfect
perfect visioning like what do I want
out of this game how can my choices one
by one get me to that point right there
how do I max out it was one you probably
have had a similar one or anyways it was
a character who was like I'm looking for
or like hey do you have any you know a
cleaning skills or like cooking skills
and I was like of the choices like yeah
like with the idea that maybe there's
like a job or like a skill like okay
great
or do you have any like you know sewing
skills like I'm like yeah I do and then
he goes perfect you're now my slave like
you know I could have done the other way
but that probably even had a similar
outcome it didn't really matter what it
was but you know I see like I clearly
get like I really did not have any of
those skills you know you mean like yeah
he's the Rams easier wreak it like the
game it just so immediately was just
like catching you're like are like you
don't ya know you don't like I know
every interaction feels really crafted
and just up in the air like you just
play it like like your stuff like it
really it really strips you of like I
don't know inhibitions I feel like it
doesn't matter my favorite example so
far that where the game encouraged me to
play role play not play a role as
someone pointed out different things but
you get what I mean this this character
was trying to seduce my character I knew
something was up like me Mike I knew
something was up and I knew that I
should not let her do her thing but my
character is much weaker so I'm like
yeah yeah kiss her oh it's fine and then
something I won't ruin it but I wouldn't
real me it was like okay I was
I shouldn't have done that but my
character like super dumb eager for love
desperate you might say she didn't mind
that I'm just a skeleton and in fact I
think she kind of liked it so that it
didn't turn out well but it did kind of
in a sense that like the game encouraged
me to role play and that's a pretty
powerful thing for a game to do and not
even trying to I'm just like oh I'm
gonna do this because yeah it makes
sense for this character I don't know
it's it's it's awesome I picked I picked
up gesture I haven't done it yet right I
just like all of these like really like
in any situations like just my character
I have like this is entertainers
[Music]
[Laughter]
instrument yeah yeah and and then also I
was the loot no no I was violent the
other oh I'm an alpha other skill I
picked was turning people into chickens
excellent yeah apparently is like an
Opie skill in some circles people are
like taking down really high it's you
can do it pretty quickly
Archer polymorpha Ranger hybrid yeah I
like him and then the best is like
turning someone to chicken and then like
you can like you know always check an
enemy's stats and then you go back and
just really dumb stats
you're a chicken now yeah they'd like
make some useless except for moving
delicious ooh yeah when you kill him
they go back into their body yeah I was
expecting like I'm having a lot of
chicken yeah so like I said as long as
there's no last-minute thoughts I kind
of want to finish up I don't want to but
I think I have finished I've divinity
original sin to chat it's a 10 out of 10
on GameSpot it's a central gay matter
what kind of games you like you should
go give this a chance we think you'll
like it a lot that review is up on games
by YouTube we got a video review written
review the 14th 10 out of 10 GameSpot's
ever given the 2nd of this year yes sir
yeah so we need help we got guides we
got guys yeah there's a lot to learn in
the ski
yeah yeah um is its on console or is it
coming to Twitter it might be coming to
console yes have controller support on
PC and will let you choose a setting to
dictate whether using PlayStation 4 or
Xbox one so you can kind of get the
console experience I was playing on my
TV with the controller on my couch felt
like it's not totally optimized for that
kind of play just yet so I actually want
to spend more time with it you know as I
should mouse and keyboard monitor in my
face right yeah yeah cuz maximum games
ported the first game to Xbox one last
two years ago the first game was 2014
but yeah like in 2015 I believe they
brought it over so judging by that
pattern it might be a year from now if
that like I don't know like they I
cannot look like certifying this game is
gonna be easy for ya well it sounds like
they who was I talking to was saying
it's already like ready to start being
shorted they like implemented that like
any good developer would do that up
front so it wouldn't take as long right
so yeah well I obviously will let you
guys know when we if we hear about that
for people who don't traditionally play
on PC could you try this game blitz
screen to where's that something rolls
but you know it is talk about co-op yeah
yeah I mean we talked about that last
week this game is a lot oh yeah it looks
John Luke found Luke invented oh and you
should we should start a new campaign we
should try that I know like a bunch of
us keep talking about it but I'm like 35
hours into my single-player I want to
try co-op more hell yeah
I kind of wanted to talk about Red Dead
to teaser tomorrow we can kind of
glossed over a little more because I
mean by the time like most people see
this if they're not watching live the
extreme love happened but Rockstar did
say they were Red Dead Redemption -
teaser coming tomorrow or at least it
was the red background with the Red Dead
type face I hope it's just a live action
teaser and that's all we get yeah just
actors so we did the stream last year
the game got delayed from last year to
sometime next year maybe there's no set
Dane q1 yeah whatever
yeah spring ish do you guys think
they'll show much just the world like
the first the teaser trailer that they
showed on that stream last year was more
like the world right oh yeah what's a
setting for sure you think you'll feel
like character time period
johnny marr mar yeah I mean what's next
I mean obviously there's they confirmed
an online component first right I don't
know if they would show that yet that's
looks like down the road right so I mean
you lookin like GTA I got implemented
after the fact
now that's they've been pushing it ever
since it would make sense to be like
characters and stuff right yeah I think
so can introduction yeah yeah hard are
they gonna lean into it being like
classic Western you know cuz I mean
around this time period I guess you know
steampunk is kind of a made-up thing
right but you could you could kind of
like imagine how they might grow out of
the Western thing a bit and how would
they do that you'd have to look at
industrialization or whatnot
yeah yeah potentially like yeah like
something I mean I would personally not
mind at all if it was hardcore Western
yeah yeah I mean it's it seems more like
in the vein of uh what am I thinking of
what's the Coen Brothers remake with
Jeff Bridges Buffalo Boys yes True Grit
thank you like east of the original game
right like more Midwest kind of Rocky
Mountain areas from what I understand so
I guess because you say is north east of
the original map which was more like
Texas Mexico wasn't there like a leaked
map this game yeah it's like Eastern
yeah northeast of like traditional
southwest or western setting yeah I
don't know we'll have a stream we're
gonna be talking before the stream so
the stream is at 11 o'clock Eastern Time
in tomorrow morning baby no more time
yeah 8 a.m. Pacific will be streaming
starting at 7:30 I think and then we're
gonna do like a pre-show and then we
gonna stream it right at 8:00 on
gamespot and then talk about it
afterward oh man I would be 8:00 huh
7:30 to start because yeah sure she'll
be around GameSpot I've got an East
Coaster like 10:30 in the office when I
get in the did last time should be fine
yeah we'll play the game a little
post-show analysis if there's enough
we'll talk about it next week on the
lobby again but we do have its nest
classic in the office and that's what
people have been clamoring for so let's
talk about that I played a little bit
today played starfox to for the first
time ever
yeah would you like it what your was
that no would have been a 95 or 96
probably I mean yeah obviously it was I
mean super novel to have you know Polly
gonna graphics on consoles like that I
mean you saw a virtual racer had some of
that on the genesis Star Fox actually
had some of that on the Super Nintendo
but those games ran at 15 frames per
second
yeah we accepted that back then well
whether I would have liked it or not I
don't know I probably would have been
curious about it I would have rented it
yeah doubt yeah it just doesn't hold up
that well it's cool to see the final
version is available finally yeah
because there's only been like leaked
prototypes for years but it's not that
it's not the starfox that maybe you're
familiar with right it's not mostly on
Rails shooting there's like there's a
lot of like ground-based stuff going on
it's sort of like a an oddly like grand
scale like tactical not even the
tactical well those two new character
that was what I was surprised by the
overworld and deciding which like
Android carrier to attack in which
planets attack was kind of like Star
Wars Battlefront to the original
speaking of Star Wars that looks like a
Star Destroyer yeah it's almost like you
can pick it's like and Ross himself is
invading the solar system so you're
picking which ships to destroy in this
like strategic overview right here so
you go attack that ship but yeah just
control wise especially on the the
controllers feel great for a remake but
the control scheme for this game is
tough because you're just using its
inverted on the pad and then also to aim
right or left when you're on the ground
because you don't have that freedom of
movement as much when you're on the
stilts whatever your Walker is called if
he's R&L to aim left and right and
actually change your plane it's
cumbersome yeah I mean it's a game that
was ahead of its time but is outdated
now we can't apparently we can't talk
about the ending but I don't think any
of us have gotten there oh Michael was
beaten it I'm hoping I can twist as our
Munim to rob Etan this game for long
dang I think I picked Falco Pepe no I
pick Falco Fox he said he'd beat it in
just over an hour
really really because it's it's more of
a score chase game than it is Wow
makes any other thing like Star Fox yeah
when I cleared out all the fighters in
one area it's up by clear time one
minute eight seconds
Star Fox two novel teen first time ever
being over here yeah yeah just great to
add some value to discuss classic which
already has a lot move on because there
are so many good games yeah yeah
not Super Ghouls and what's you like
that kid yeah dude
are you messing with me no you like
super ghouls and ghosts or you know
super ghouls and ghosts a cop the Capcom
game yeah the one where the one once you
double jump you're locked into yeah that
one yes the one where you throw Spears
and where you lose your armor you're
running around in your underwear
the one where infinitely attack you yeah
okay
so in goodness you like that game okay
talk about I grew up with it wrong
opinion would super metroids obvious
bound Final Fantasy six Secret of Mana
Donkey Kong Country Mega Man X Yoshi's
Island Yoshi's my Legend of Zelda link
to the past
tomorrow world to my world donkey can't
you say Donkey Kong Country Mart
Mario it was the first time that game
has been re-released since the original
was at 96 I believe so think Michael hi
I'm was played that over the way yeah
yeah and that was a square Nintendo
joint so that was a very interesting
collaboration back in the day I kind of
touched on it before we talk more about
the games controls feel great yeah
the bumper buttons feel better than I
remember them feeling in the original
Ness but maybe that's because the one I
played on there's a long mission we had
an original one in the office and we
compared they're like identical yeah
really yeah maybe it's just like
everything about maybe I was expecting
them to feel worse because like I said
you could barely even tell the
difference other than like one was a
little bit more faded but obviously the
console itself is different
it's so cute tiny it was pretty adorable
it's nice pressing reset and then going
right back to the menu screen to play
all those games yeah I wish you could do
it from the controller somehow but it's
not that's like the worst thing you can
say about it my attention Mega Man X
great game
that one what do you love Rob I like the
concave button of holding that like it's
been so freakin hot like X&Y yeah didn't
have that they were all convex damn is
that a comparison or these both is
classic control which one do you think
is which Oh which one I think they are
the same size the one on the one on the
right is the senesce classic there looks
so much more faded what is it yeah the
one on the right is this classic oh
that's a double what it's more matte
kind of you've call it faded but I call
it obvious I do what that was a really
good quality originals nest controller
though yeah that one looked nice yeah if
that were in my house it would have been
like gross and like Sun faded covered in
dust yeah chocolate from your little
brother or whatever yeah so this is we
mentioned this before a lot of great
games 23 121 - of course Chrono Trigger
is not on there and that was the big be
like yeah still don't know what happened
behind the scenes for that not to come
to it I don't know who knows I mean
there's a lot of great games that
deserve to be on this thing that is just
sort of the one where you're like yeah
that would really have just completed
the thing you know the whole package a
little bummed also that pilotwings
wasn't on there I love pilot wings it's
a very very good game and it's got so
many different experiences within it
that would that would have been really
nice because there are no it's not
really a sports game but it's like close
to sports it's just you know it and
there's nothing like that on the system
at the moment yeah what about in
comparison to the classic are gonna yes
NES close yes excuse me um had like in
the manual you know you abilities to
like change the filter and yeah you can
do that here you can add it straight at
skate lions and you can change the
background stuff anything like are there
more Instagram filters for it like what
would put scanlines over it and the
scale answered are they sort of it's not
just the lines they they blur the image
as well to make it look a little bit
faded
but I I wouldn't recommend those not in
this instance
I like scanlines I'm games but not not
these here's my cue for your a hopefully
what do you think this is worth okay
this is I mean obviously clear there's a
lot of value there's 21 fantastic games
well there's a lot of fantastic games in
this collection of 21 games do you think
there's more to this than seeing
nostalgia do you think people who have
never played any of these games who
maybe never touch this nest do you think
this is worth grabbing I do this day and
age I think they'll play something like
Mario Kart and be like yeah yeah you
know I think they'll play earthbound and
they'll be pleasantly surprised by the
writing but maybe a little bit bored by
the combat yeah you know but you look at
some games like a Link to the Past yeah
Super Metroid and I'm not a huge Donkey
Kong Country fan but I will admit my own
country is it is a timeless game it's
got one of the best soundtracks and
controlling wonderfully like really good
like especially when you consider like
the limitations of what you're working
with really good lighting and just sort
of atmosphere I think there are so many
games on the system that would convince
anybody that this thing is worth owning
if they like video games Super Mario
World
yes yes Super Mario well yours island is
contentious yeah yeah it's great to see
like in a year when Nintendo is doing
super well with their current console
obviously that an NES classic coming
back next year is good despite the fact
that they kind of bungled the purposely
or accidentally bungled the supply
issues last year that's extending the
production into next year was a good
move on their part yeah hopefully they
continue because I haven't gotten mine
yet I know you guys are all waiting no
Rob you had a snafu right oh god how
they charge for pre-orders basically Rob
did not even credit card no my car got
canceled and I thought the payment
already went through my card I cancelled
my card I knew I'm currently living on
the street no and I wish they like gave
me a notification or something but it
was just like hey guess what you blew it
you see NASA's gone you blew it I was
like a school I didn't deserve it
they're like yeah we now I want to ask
you Pete quick as someone who spent some
time with this what's your
favorite game in this collection pick
one it has to be only to the past yeah
the only answer yeah I mean this and
follow fantasy six or three our that's
the one I'm super that's way up there
but that's the world yeah I'm with you
it is you're not you're not wrong to the
past axis is like the closest to perfect
it yeah if you want to talk just about
so much in there the diversity of
experiences and the things that are
expected of you are far greater in this
than Super Mario World
yeah Super Mario World is I mean how do
you pick how do you how do you really do
that Isaac man I was listening to a
podcast this morning where a guy was
talking about you know just to be
incredibly nostalgic
you know growing up as a kid playing a
Link to the Past and like dislike me
like save his game and turn it off so he
could watch the new episodes of The
Simpsons and the next ship in a Star
Trek next generation you ever suppose
shows and turn this back on like I I
mean I think I do think these games
outlive nostalgia but it's also just it
it really does bring me back and I don't
want to say Nintendo is doing it in a
cynical way I don't know that they're
doing it from a romantic way either but
it has that effect on me so yeah this
this is just one of the the coolest
things to come out in years in my
opinion yeah it's especially if you try
to collect these games
I decide what I honestly like I'm so
pumped to play Final Fantasy 3 for the
first time yeah never played that I know
chasing forever what you say have fun
with random and yeah yeah right because
I I think back to like Chrono Trigger
they didn't they would just you would
see the people right before you effect
random encounters are pretty much the
only downfall to that game my opinion
yeah uh cool so yeah we have a full
review from Michael hi I'm one on our
tech team and he played it all weekend
it sounds like he played a bunch of
games I think he played through Super
Mario RPG again which is also a
fantastic game mm-hmm I like the well so
go check that out full review on
GameSpot that's pretty much our show
today talk to Vinnie talks Ness classic
Runner a little bit of heat signature
some TGS news if you're not watching
this live we are doing this every
Wednesday at 11 a.m. like I said
tomorrow which is what
tomorrow Thursday the 27th of September
starting at 8:00 like 30
no sorry 7:30 a.m. Pacific will be
starting to stream the pre-show for the
Red Dead Redemption to new trailer tease
or whatever the Rockstar does then we'll
watch it here and then do a little post
show that's pretty much it
Peter you should join us you might be
streaming cuphead this week we got
cuphead codon yeah I got a review spots
one that game looks tough the embargo is
Friday yeah and as always be able
giveaway so I'll do that really quick
the Marvel vs. Capcom infinite
collector's edition for ps4 we did an
unboxing of this the deluxe edition
sorry we didn't unboxing this you get
the four you get to me you get Captain
Marvel like a madman and Mega Man X and
six eggs you can go watch the unboxing
six yeah I don't know go watch our
unboxing you could see closer out Joey
he did a he bought his own and we
unboxed that but you get the art book
and everything so yeah we will announce
the winner on Friday according to Shiva
she's gonna put the giveaway link in the
twitch chat but otherwise you could just
go to Twitter follow gamespot if you
don't already and retweet the giveaway
tweet itself will pick winners randomly
Friday so that's pretty much it as
always thanks to Eric taejong leukocyte
key Richard Lee in the back thank you
Peter Cali Rob for joining me we'll be
back next week maybe some cuphead shadow
of war no nevermind that's like a day
after dammit okay yeah so that's pretty
much it
thanks for joining me guys any last
thoughts longer
Abbie deco oh nice nice again I saw I
wanna play it again yeah I want to play
it again me too you do that was good
[Laughter]
YouTube GameSpot twitch like I said
we'll be back next week thank you
everybody in the back we will see you
next Wednesday 11:00 a.m. Pacific
[Music]